we're going to prove a handful of
related results to do with prime numbers
divisibility and for some reason some
very long algebraic expansions so
let's dive right in show that
x to the n minus 1 is equal to and then
they provide this uh factorization for
you which looks
really overpowered like why would you
write something so nice and concise and
succinct in such a long and awkward way
well it's going to be useful for part b
so let's have a go at this
part a uh x to the n minus one
um is going to be equal to this right
hand side here so i think the easiest
way to have a go at this
is to start with the right hand side i'm
see daisy
and then hopefully if i expanded i
should arrive at this nice simplified
thing
on the left hand side so i'm going to
start by writing the x minus one but i'm
going to
employ a trick that i've done before
which is to write one of these terms
in one color another the next term in
the binomial
in a different color and that will make
it easier for me to sift out what's
going on when i expand when i distribute
all of these terms
so x to the n minus one x to the n minus
two
establish the pattern with the third one
uh
dot dot dot uh i actually don't think i
need to do the last three terms i'm just
going to do
i'm just going to do the last two i
think we'll do it
all right so i've got my
algebraic sort of brackets ready to go
let's start expanding i'm going to do
the x's first
so when i multiply this first term here
by x
this is x minus x to the n minus 1 times
x to the 1 so we add the indices
and we just get x to the n the next one
along is just one power down so it's x
to the n minus 1
plus x to the n minus 2 and then so on
when i get to the end that x turns into
an x squared
and then the 1 turns into an x and
that's it i have distributed everything
from the x's now i'm going to do the
minus ones and they're even easier
for reasons that you might recognize
before i even say it i'm gonna stagger
these terms and move them one along
just to make some cancelling and
collection of like terms easier in a
second so
here we go minus one minus x to the n
minus one
minus x to the n minus 2
minus x to the n minus 3 just to
continue the pattern minus dot dot dot
and then my last terms are x and
1. and and that's it so what do i see
here well
a whole lot of this is going to collapse
and cancel with each other which is what
i was hoping for
my x to the n minus 1 terms of course
cancel x to the n minus 2 terms
cancel this x to the n minus 3 would
cancel if i'd written all the terms
there
but you'll also see the and the same
thing with the x squared
but then lastly you see these x's cancel
which leave you with these
uh terms here x to the n and the minus
one which is of course what i was after
so
x to the n minus one as required
okay wonderful how am i going to use
these for
part b well you're going to see these
are some of those questions where
there's very little working
actually but a lot of thinking that's
involved underneath them so
what's the first one we want to look at
here prove that s 7 to the n minus 1
is divisible by 6. for all values of n
where
n is a positive integer okay so how does
this work before we actually
do the proof i just want to note like
what are these numbers seven to the n
minus one well seven to the one minus
one uh
seven is uh seven to the one rather is
seven minus one which equals six
obviously that's divisible by six what's
the next one 49 minus one is 48
that's divisible by six great the next
one along is 343 take away one
um 342 sure i guess so 300 divisible by
6
42 divisible by 6 looks good and the
last one i know off the top of my head
is two thousand four hundred and one you
subtract one
and you get two thousand four hundred
which again fairly uncontroversially
is divisible by six so it's nice we can
at least see it works
how do we prove it what i'm gonna do
simply is to use part a
for part one i'm going to say well let's
let x take on a value that's appropriate
to this question
and fairly obviously it's 7. so if x
equals 7
therefore from part a
i can say 7 to the n minus 1 which is
remember the thing i want to prove is
is divisible by 6 is just equal to and
i'm just going to use
i'm just going to quote the result
substituting in 7 for x so i get 7 minus
1
and then i've got 7 to the n minus 1 7
to the n minus 2
uh 7 to the n minus 3 establishes the
platen dot
dot plus um what am i going to have down
the end there
plus 7 plus 1. okay
now what you can see here hopefully is
that on the left hand side here
or on the left part of the right hand
side 7 take away 1 that's simply equal
to 6
which is going to be very important to
me in a second that's multiplied by
everything over here and there's not
much that i can do
to simplify this now where is the
working
involved next well you actually just
need to think about this object that
you've got over here
remember what you've got here is going
to be a series
of integers because even though we start
with this 7 to the n
minus 1 the lowest value that
n can take is going to be let's see here
it's a positive integer so n has to be
equal to 1 which means that the 7 to the
1 minus 1 is 7 to the 0
which would be 1 there'd only be one
term over there and we saw that already
it's 6 times 1
which is this first case over here so
even though there are several terms here
we've written this series just in case
we need that many depending on what n
is but the smallest this thing is going
to get is 1.
when you do the next one it'll be 1 plus
7 which is 8 which is why we got
48 before because that's 6 x
8. so what you can see here is a series
of integers this is a series of
whole numbers positive whole numbers as
well so therefore
i've got 6 times n
where n equals
seven to the n minus one seven to the n
minus two
is a capital n which is a bit sneaky but
anyway um plus dot dot dot all the way
to one
um so n is also a positive
integer and so if you have some number 7
to the n
minus 1 it can be rewritten as 6
times some other positive integer which
is the definition of
divisibility by 6. so that's kind of it
there's not that much working to it you
just need to think carefully about the
objects that you've got
and then do a little bit of cancelling
okay
now you're going to follow this theme
when you have a look at part two we're
going to use the same algebraic result
but to do something a little bit
different right
if 80 n minus 1 is prime then a equals
2. this actually relates to a question
that we looked at earlier with the
mercen primes
these are the numbers of the form 2 to
the n minus
1 where in fact if 2 to the n minus 1 is
prime we can know that n
itself is prime and this is the way we
actually calculate all large
prime numbers so how do i prove this
well i'm going to start by using the
result
that we proved in part a except instead
of an x
i'm just going to write an a so what do
we get here i'm going to write
a to the n minus 1 is equal to a minus 1
and then here comes the rest of the
brackets a to the n minus 1
a to the n minus 2 n minus 3
dot dot dot where do we finish a squared
plus a plus 1. and then the other thing
they tell us is that a to the n minus 1
is prime now hold on a second
if a to the n minus 1 is prime then it
can't possibly be written
as the product of two prime numbers
but that's an issue right because look
i've got this number over here being
multiplied by this number over here
i should say not just two prime numbers
you definitely can't be the product of
two
composite numbers because then you're
definitely not going to be prime
so if this is prime and it speaks
expressed on the right hand side as the
product
of two positive integers the only way
this can work out is if one of the
positive integers
is equal to one right think about this
right if i want the product of two
positive integers to give me a prime
number
those two positive integers better be
one and a prime number
if they're both prime you you don't get
a
prime number at the end as a product if
they're if neither of them
is um prime then you're already in
trouble so one
and a prime that will do it and the
reason why i'm highlighting that this
has to be
the other non-one number is that you
start with one and then this thing gets
bigger
as a increases so this part this factor
over here
this one can't be one it has to be this
this has to be equal to one so therefore
4 a to the n minus 1 to b
prime oops that minus 1 should be down
here
i can say a minus 1 has to equal
1. and it carries it's an if and only if
statement
that therefore i can add one to both
sides and i get a equals two
which was the result that i was trying
to prove um
and i guess my reasoning would be um
since if
if a is not two this is proved by contra
positive
if a is not equal to two then a minus
one isn't equal to one
and that means you've got these two
things here can't possibly when you
multiply them together
give you a prime number so i guess the
moral of the story is
even though it's not complicated working
you need to think carefully about the
objects that you've got
and i guess the attributes and qualities
that they have because
that's the kind of thing that we use to
prove these results